r
entre retourner en Europe ou
attendre que cette frontière
terrestre ouvre à nouveau.
(pleurs)
- Une journée difficile
pour la famille de Nikita
Golboroudjkonecki.
Épuisée, la petite Nicole,
3 ans et demi est arrivée avec
son père et sa mère Natalie,
dans ce campement de fortune
d'Ukrainiens qui arrivent par
milliers depuis des semaines
ici.
Parti de la Pologne, leur
voyage aura duré 24 heures pour
arriver à Tijuana, sur la côte
t t t t du Mexique. Plus rien
ne retenait la famille dans
son pays.
ouououout ce qui lui reste se te
dans ses quelques bagages.
Il a fait comme tous ces
Ukrainiens qui n'ont pas voulu
attendre des mois pour avíO
des nouvelles de leur dossier
d'immigration déposé dans
des ambassades américaines
en Europe, et qui étaient
submergées par les demandes
de réfugiés ou de demandeurs
d'asile.
Alors, ils ont profité
d'une exemption spéciale de
l'administration Biden qui
leur paiaiaiait de traverser
la frontière terrestre via
le Mexique alors que celle-ci
est fermée à l'ensemble
grgrgrgrgrants depuis le début
de la pandémie en 2020.
Depuis le début de l'invasion
russe, Anastasia Bolo,
co-fondatrice de United for
Ukraine, dit avoir accueilli
près de 12 000 personnes ici,
des personnes de passage,
à quelqu"<
z+Qes de
sportif transformé en dortoir.
Mais tous ces Ukrainiens
exténués par leur périple
et les déchirements d'avoir
dû quitter leur pays et leur
famille sont probablement
parmi les derniers à pouvoir
profiter de l'accu
des autorités américaines.
Car depuis minuit, ce passe-
droit n'existe plus pour ceux
qui ont fui la guerre.
Enrique Lucero, responsable
des services aux migrants,
à la Ville de Tijuana, sait
que cela sera difficile pourrtr.
Dans ce camp, nous rencontrons
aussi Pavel, sa femme Alyona
et leur fils de 12 ans, Dima.
Leurucucucucucucucoup
plus compliqué que ceux
des Ukrainiens ici. Il est Russe
et a quitté Moscou après avoir
manifesté contre la guerre.
Il ne sait ce qui va lui
arriver car les services
d'immigration américaine
ne veulent pas l'aider.
Il ne peut même plus retourner
dans son pays. Son fils veut
quand même croire à un meilleur
avenir de l'autre côté de
la f
Pendant ce temps, Anastasia
Bolo songe déjà à d'autres
idées pour éviter que tous
ces Ukrainiens soient laissés
à eux-mêmes à Tijuana.
Dans quelques minutes,
Nikita passera la frontière
pour aller vivre à San Diégo
chez des amis.
Un avenir qui ne le fera
donc pas re.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.
Il construira plutôt sa
nouvelle vie aux États-Unis,
mais il pensera à ses semblables
qui ne traverseront pas de sitôt
cettanananananananananant
tant espérée.
Ici Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, à Tijuana,
au Mexiqu